Charles asks is the askgaryvee show your
version of meditation it seems like it
helps you organize your thoughts Charles
this is a really good question i saw
this one come through the stream and I
and I it took me a step back because I'm
like does it like you know what I can
tell you is this i think the brilliance
of the askgaryvee show when the business
historians look back at it is so awesome
anyway when people look back when I look
back when the team looks back when you
the collective audience looks back when
you the person that's watching this
video three years from now look at this
show and realize that I was on it was
we've created this show as a foundation
point to all the other content that I'm
putting out and so the ability to use
this show that then allows India and
Steve to help me right medium form
content I mean I think all of you have
seen that over the last you know six to
eight weeks my ability to pump out
medium and gary vaynerchuk calm animated
gifts all these things are all coming
from this central seed so the ability to
put out this show which brings a lot of
value to a lot of people it's one great
jab at the highest levels for the people
that know what I'm referring to and then
it's also a gateway drug to more content
that is content made to be gateway drugs
to awareness about me and to create
leverage it's just one big machine of
brilliance oh crap wait subscribe do I
need subscriptions because I can't push
this many right hooks in social so
subscribe